Homeland Security secretary Alejandro
mayorkas is facing a lot of tough
questions on Capitol Hill right now many
of them about a chilling new report on
the border crisis and its impact on
unaccompanied migrant children the New
York Times out with this new report
revealing an alarming increase in
migrant children forced to work brutal
jobs in this country and at the White
House and federal agencies knew about it
but they turned a blind eye the paper
writing this over the past two years
more than 250 000 migrant children have
come alone to the United States
thousands of children have ended up in
punishing jobs across the country
working overnight in slaughterhouses
replacing roofs operating machinery and
factories all in violation of child
labor laws a recent times investigation
showed all along there were sides of the
explosive growth of this labor force and
warnings that the Biden Administration
ignored or missed it the administration
is pushing back on the reporting the
times rights HHS officials said the
department vetted sponsor sufficiently
but could not control what happened to
children after they were released
officials at the labor department said
inspectors had increased their focus on
child labor and shared details about
workers with HHS but said it was not a
welfare agency and White House officials
said that while the two departments had
passed long information about migrant
child labor the reports were not flagged
as urgent and did not make the scope of
the problem clear lawmakers at today's
hearing brought up the report
we have no idea who those people are
what kind of security they risk you're
not giving me any stats whatsoever in
terms of the number of people that are
human trafficked how many young girls
are sex trafficked
you you don't have a clue you wouldn't
you wouldn't even answer how many dead
bodies which is very well documented
at the border
do you not care do you not have just an
ounce of human compassion for what your
open border policy the type of human
depredations it is causing
you just sit there looking with a blank
look on your face and you're saying it's
a priority
a quarter of a million children have
come Ainsley let's talk about a little
boy named Antonio he had to drop out of
school he had to work at a refrigeration
Factory these were the conditions
Antonio he was placed by the way with a
a sponsor in Florida no one ever checked
up on him he said he went days sometimes
without having any contact with anyone
he said this and um or this is the
summation of it instead of continuing to
ninth grade Antonio found the job
packing vegetables he worked numbing
shifts that left him chilled each night
even though he wore the heaviest jacket
he could afford in the obscene part to
me Ainsley is that the reports of this
allegedly made it to Xavier becerra's
desk cabinet secretary and Senior White
House officials were shown evidence of
exploitation such as clusters of Migrant
children who'd been found working with
industrial equipment or caustic
chemicals they did nothing about it and
that's only one child Kaylee this is a
an account from Linda brand Miller if
you have a chance to read the article I
highly recom and it's hard to read
because we all love our children and
can't imagine as a mom sending my little
girl to another country by herself some
of these little kids on the side of the
road holding a teddy bear crying asking
for mom or dad picking them up in the in
the Rio Grande in the Water Swimming by
themselves it's really it's really sad
and Linda brand Miller had a heart for
these children she started working in
the arena in San Antonio that was
converted to a shelter her job was to
vet these sponsors she said she flagged
this one man who came and said I need
three boys to work at my construction
company she contacted the government
supervisors and said this is urgent in
an email she never heard back another
Florida man wanted two kids and would
have worked off because he says they
need to come and live with me to work
off the cost it's it's worth being
charged to bring them up from Mexico or
from Guatemala and one of and he was one
of the ones who got the 14 year old boy
that you were talking about and she sent
another email immediate attention and
then she was fired she let her direct
supervisor know in San Antonio and she
her key card or whatever was removed and
she was fired from the job she calls
stepping on a whistleblower five HHS
officials fired in fact five uh it's
astonishing Ian one thing that caught my
attention in this article was an account
about Susan Rice we all know Big White
House advisor huge role in the
administration here's what it said in
2021 as images of children sleeping
under foil blankets and overflow centers
dominated the news Susan E rice the
White House's head of domestic policy
told staff members she was frustrated
with the situation according to five
people who worked with her Miss rice
vented in a note she scribbled on a memo
detailing the position of Advocates who
believed a pandemic era border closure
was compelling parents to send
unaccompanied children called UCS This
is BS Miss rice wrote according to a
copy of the memo reviewed by the times
what is leading to voluntary separation
is our generosity now the White House
denies this but this is essentially if
true her admitting that they've
incentivized all of these problems well
they have and if you go back to the
Trump Administration and look at what
HHS does you know HHS is responsible for
resettling children that come across the
border in America and you get all these
people come in and they say they're
family members and you know some of them
may be family members but some of them
may be involved in human trafficking
some of them are Smugglers that are
putting them in these workplaces the
Trump Administration was able to get the
border under control so it was a
disincentive for Smugglers to to really
go through but then the Bible
Administration comes in and wipes all
those policies out so what do you expect
as you now have an incentive for
Smugglers and most of these kids are
between 13 and 18 and can work so you go
there and maybe you say that oh I'm a
parent I'm a cousin I'm an uncle but
you're maybe not and then they come in
and they get involved in all these other
activities and we have absolutely no way
to track them and that is what happened
as a result of Biden really erasing
those very effective Trump border
policies now we're dealing with this
situation and Harris we've covered on
outnumbered the plight of Migrant
children it's been reported CBS migrant
children endure Despair and isolation
reports of them eating raw uncooked
chicken we've covered it here and the
Biden Administration essentially turned
a blind eye although AOC had those
tearful pictures at the porter yeah you
know what you said was really I don't
want people to miss what you said they
could be somebody who's picking those
kids up who are on a list and they could
also be people who are going to sex
traffick them so two things can be true
I mean that's what's really sad about
this Senator Blackburn of Tennessee
first brought to our uh coverage over a
year ago those surreptitious flights
into her State since then she has been
really on the case to figure out what
happened to those children in particular
because there were so many flights
coming in in the middle of the night
just in her State alone but across the
country New Jersey my state Just landing
at two o'clock in the with little ones
this big getting off the point not not
attached to anybody who might be on a
list here's Senator Blackburn from last
hour on the focus
we know that Health and Human Services
office of refugee resettlement has
completely lost track of 85
000 children that have come into this
country we know that you've got over 250
000 unaccompanied Alien Children and
they can't find 85 000 of them you
reference The Whistleblower and what
we're hearing is that many of these
children are going to individuals who
want to use them as child labor this is
something that has to stop
has to stop so how do you stop it well
first of all you got to go find 85 000
kids yeah and and second of all you've
got to figure out what is happening at
the border such that those children
don't get special attention I thought
this was the administration that was
going to be different remember oh we
don't put kids in cages well actually
that was Obama so let's get the facts
straight on that but we're not going to
separate remember Trump got so much
grief and criticism about the separation
of children this Administration said
we're going to be different well they're
not separating them they're completely
whole body whole cloth losing them
they're losing thousands of children who
already were disadvantaged when they
came they already were up against it
they'd been in the arms of cartels they
who knows what their treks had been and
you're going to further normalize abuse
normalize abuse further their Pain by
putting them in basically slave
conditions in this country to labor at
the the hands of someone who picks them
up and AOC you know she found a time to
shed tears at the border during the
Trump era where is she now where is Vice
President Kamala Harris visiting these
facilities checking on these children
well it's because all of that those
crocodile tears were performative
activism it's performative compassion
and it's the amount of compassion that
leads to Cruelty I think about as you
were describing Harris that little ones
being you know just abandoned I'm
picturing that image that we had here on
Fox News the video of a child that was
floating down the Rio Grande river and
that to me just represents the level of
Abandonment by this Administration and
the policies that led to the push
factors abandoning that child in the
river I think about as well how part and
parcel to this Administration it's all
about the blame game so we know that
veteran staffers senior officials
contractors raise the alarm as you
described making its way up to becerra's
desk to HHS what was hhs's response no
no that's a Department of Labor issue
we're not a welfare system it reminds me
of when Nadler said to that grieving
mother's face well fifty percent of the
killers were caught Madeleine there is a
level of deflection and refusal of
responsibility that this Administration
takes that is appalling and to use your
word Kaylee it is obscene but it won't
end anytime soon and uh who gets lost in
the San Antonio who goes to youth group
who deserves to be able to go to school
and doesn't his grandmother to work who
misses his grandmother hey everyone I'm
Emily compagno catch me and my co-host
Harris Faulkner and Kaylee mcineny on
outnumbered every weekday at 12 pm
Eastern or sets your DVR also don't
forget to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page for daily highlights